[Music]
it was definitely a blur you know I want
to take you know total responsibility
for everything but if you had asked me
you know that morning was I gonna wake
up and kill somebody there there would
have been no way and I think initially I
was trying to scare him and Moore came
out of me then even I knew was there
this is one of those things that no
matter how many of men's you make you
can never take it back there would be
nothing that I would wish more than to
be able to give mark in his life back
that's Chris Schumacher and this is the
retro podcast
[Music]
the rich roll podcast hey everybody how
you guys doing what's happening my name
is rich roll I am your friendly podcast
host welcome to the show
today's guest is a man I met through my
friend Tom Scott who you may recall from
the podcast episode 360 at the Nantucket
project last year his name is Chris
Schumacher and his story is a story of
mistakes made in particular one very
profound life-ending mistake it's a
story of penance served and really the
long hard rock path to atonement to self
forgiveness and ultimately redemption
it's a very human story it's raw it's
messy perhaps controversial but it's one
I felt moved to tell and it begins with
a smart guy a standout volleyball player
an Air Force veteran a guy who spent
nearly two years at the Defense Language
Institute Monterey California studying
Korean but along the way Chris starts to
make some bad decisions a long line of
errant decisions in fact decisions that
lead to a heart partying lifestyle in
Los Angeles decisions that led to
dealing weed to support that lifestyle
and decisions that conspire that
ultimately culminated in one fateful day
where in a suitcase of drugs he was
dispatched to sell were stolen from him
and then in this drug and alcohol fueled
rage really desperate and I would
imagine fearing of the consequences of
what would happen if he didn't retrieve
this suitcase Chris ends up taking
another man's life he's convicted of
murder he's sentenced to 16 to life and
he walks into prison having to navigate
the gangs the racial tensions all the
unwritten rules that are part and parcel
of that lifestyle all well knowing that
as a lifer there was a very good chance
that he was never going to get out now
I'd like to preface
this conversation by saying that there
is a lot more to Chris's story but of
course before we get into it I have to
warn that this is a tough one
not because it's graphic or because of
the language but but because of the
gravity of course of taking another
human beings life it's not something to
be minimized it's very serious and not
to be diminished but Chris's journey is
as instructive I think as it is profound
so my hope is that you will listen with
an open mind so one of the reasons that
I felt compelled to have Chris share his
story is to provide some nuance to the
debacle that is our current criminal
justice system right now there are
somewhere around 2.3 million locked up
in more than 6,000 correctional
facilities across the United States and
from 1972 to 2010 the number of people
in prison in the US has increased seven
hundred percent seven hundred percent
twenty five percent of the world's
incarcerated population is in the United
States and in California we spend more
on prisons than we do on higher
education cost about forty seven
thousand dollars to keep one prisoner in
jail in California for a year and more
than 67 percent of the state prisoners
released in 2005 were arrested within
the next three years so this isn't a
great picture there's a lot that's not
correct about how we're doing all of
this so is there a better way to deal
with people who commit acts of violence
and and how do we prevent them from
committing them again so low crime
punishment these are a part of life
sadly even murder but we do need to face
these issues we need to prioritize in my
opinion rehabilitation and innovate new
solutions that promote it for a more
effective results and Chris is the
product of this movement into innovative
rehabilitation you know on the off
chance that this guy would get a second
chance while he was inside Chris
committed to taking responsibility he
got sober got a college degree he joined
this amazing program called the last
mile which we're going to talk about
where he learned programming software
engineering and ultimately develops this
app this Fitness app called Fitness
monkey and then about two years ago
after serving 17 years a Parole Board
granted him his freedom and he's now
blazing his way into becoming a
productive member of society so like I
mentioned up top this one is intense we
recorded it several months ago when I
was visiting the Bay Area so there's no
video for this episode and it's a story
about drugs alcohol addiction it's about
betrayal anger and of course tragically
murder but it's also about atonement
it's about the path to redemption and
his journey towards becoming this
productive member of society and so I
think baked into that it's really about
empathy so there's no undoing what Chris
did but I do think there is something
profound and and something instructive
about how he leaned into
self-examination personal responsibility
faith sobriety fitness and education to
ultimately transform himself into being
the kind of person that he always knew
he could be and so here we are and this
is his story
all right Chris thank you so much for
doing this today man it's a pleasure to
reconnect with you after Nantucket
project yeah great to be here rich
thanks for having me
so we're taping this in a nondescript
little business meeting conference room
no hotel at all Alto I just flew up here
this morning from Los Angeles and for
those of you that are listening we're on
day three of the Malibu Calabasas
Inferno and it looks like the
firefighters are finally getting the
upper hand on this thing but we're still
displaced from our home and it's been a
pretty chaotic insane past couple days
lots of friends who lost their homes and
not a lot of sleep on my part so if my
thoughts seem disjointed today Kris is
gonna have to pick up the pieces and
make this thing move but I'm gonna do
the best I can
I've been looking forward to having this
conversation for a while I first met
Chris at the Nantucket project was that
like two months ago or something like
that through our mutual friend Tom Scott
was very impacted by his message and
felt strongly that I wanted to share it
with all of you guys today so thank you
again for carving out the time you have
the day off it's Veterans Day otherwise
you'd be at your job phandom yeah so
what a year what are you doing there
like what are your responsibilities I'm
working as a software engineer I work on
the website and we're currently working
on a new community builder and phantom
is like the Wikipedia for everything
Marvel Super Heroes Game of Thrones
Netflix anything people binge watch
uh-huh that we have a place where they
can create communities around these
shows and these video games we get over
200 million unique views on the side
every month is over 400,000 communities
uh-huh I mean if you've ever heard of uh
like Star Wars has a huge community
called Wikipedia I didn't even know that
it's huge and anything runescape is big
elderscrolls if you if your kids play
any video games and look up anything
online I guarantee you they've been on
one of fandoms sites right so is it like
message boards like reddit for pop
culture it's it's similar but it also
gives them a chance it's more like like
a webpage like and they can upload video
content images they can share theirs
chat features and right now the project
that we're working on is that I mean
we've been around since 2005 and the
project we're working on is updating all
the tools that people can use because so
many things are going mobile now we want
to make a more friendly intuitive mobile
experience right and so you're you're a
coder write your code monkey I am it's
awesome you know I've always been a math
guy I also had an aptitude for languages
that I found while I was in the military
so I shout out to all the veterans out
there on Veterans Day yeah you study
Korean right I did at while I was in the
Air Force in Monterey super tough but I
found that with coding and you know I
found coding inside prison right I was
served in a 16 year at a life sentence
murder and really decided early on to
get clean and sober and to try to use
every day that that I was locked up
inside there to try to try to better my
situation to make the most out of my
time inside and it wasn't until 2012
that a program called the last mile
started in an entrepreneurship class
inside the walls of San Quentin
right so as a six month class they
taught us how to write business plans
they taught us to cultivate our own
ideas about something that we were
passionate about something that involved
technology and something with the social
cause and for me my passion was around
staying clean and also working out
running playing tennis doing yoga so
that was what inspired Fitness monkey
and I designed it to be an online life
coaching platform that empowered
addiction recovery through physical
fitness right and that's why I was
actually so impressed by your talk at
the Nantucket project because I felt
like you were one of my people you know
definitely one of your people I was
spared the prison sentence which we
couldn't get into in a minute but I
certainly share your passion for fitness
and and for recovery from drugs and
alcohol and where those two coincide and
fitness monkey you know really is unique
and that it bridges that gap like I have
apps on my phone for recovery and then I
have fitness apps but I don't have an
app that combines of the two of them and
kind of is a platform for using Fitness
as a tool in sobriety so it's super cool
and are you you're not on that you're
not are you in the App Store yet and I
look for it I couldn't find it not quite
yet we have a website and the app is
currently in development I was working
with Santa Clara University here I think
in Palo Alto right right here in the
South Bay and they were signing me grad
students to help me build the mobile app
and so I would go down and I would meet
with the students and I would lay out
the vision of how we're going to build
this thing and then two weeks later one
of them would get a job and I'd have to
start all over again
so I think I've come to the conclusion
that I'm gonna have to build it myself
mmm thank you to the last mile who you
know for the last two and a half years
while I was in San Quentin learned how
to code yeah now you know how to do it
and figure it out so and and I think
there's like a lot of empowerment in
being able to build this thing myself
right but the development cycle is going
to take a little bit longer maybe just a
yeah right it's gonna be a very rough
prototype well let's walk it back I want
to work our way towards this present
moment you have a pretty incredible
story of redemption it's remarkable that
you're even sitting here today and it's
inspiring that it's inspiring how you
took this you know bottom that you had
and grabbed onto a lifeline with the
help and support of others like the last
mile to really rebuild your life in an
amazing way so let's let's tell that
story from the beginning
sure so you grew up you were raised by
your grandparents initially right I was
adopted very early on by my grandparents
uh-huh and and so just paint the picture
of your childhood for me a little bit
it's sure I was adopted by my
grandparents I grew up knowing my
biological mother as my sister and my I
just knew my grandparents as my mom and
dad and that's so it's been my whole
life so even though biological
relationships are still there the roles
that people played in my life are super
important to me mmm they divorced when I
was five and I went to live with my mom
it was my grandmother and it was just me
and her growing up grew up in Southern
California had a pretty good home
environment went to school wasn't wasn't
super great at it didn't take it
seriously I feel like I was one of those
kids that had a lot of potential but uh
kind of chose to do other things screwed
off so much potential
which is a blessing and a gift I don't
so I mean were you like class clown or
just partier from day one or you know
where you points forth so be what you
know what kind of kid who was your crowd
yeah I was definitely I was a volleyball
guy I know Southern California fell in
love with beach volleyball
everything that's engine Smith and Randy
stow clothes and all those guys were
doing that that's what I saw that I
wanted to do and also write about the
same time you know I think I got into
drinking just like a lot of high school
kids do and I thought it was normal you
know I really did the way I drank you
know and at the time I just seemed like
everybody was doing it like that and it
really wasn't until later on that I
realized that I was probably going
overboard uh-huh
and there was a lot of consequences and
a lot of like warning signs that I blew
right past right was there a moment when
you first realized like hey you know my
relationship with alcohol is a little
bit different from my buddies like I
know for me I mean I started a little
bit later than you but pretty early on
you know I normalized the whole thing
and just you know I was like I'm just
doing what every college kid does but
looking back on it now I was like oh
yeah I was always kind of like the last
guy to leave the party or the one who
had the most embarrassing story you know
that we would laugh about it was no big
deal at the time
but there were those clear Demark you
know that sort of those of those like
red flags are being raised pretty early
and it would be many many years before
our I would take responsibility for that
but looking back it was kind of like
yeah from the beginning it was a problem
I mean was that for you or did it start
off you're just you know doing what
everyone else is doing
III feel like it started off like I was
just doing what everybody else was doing
I graduated high school I started
college I did I didn't finish one unit
while I was there I moved down to the
beach to be closer to to volleyball and
to what I thought I wanted to do with my
life but after dropping out of college I
kind of wandered for a while right down
to the beach like South Bay or where
were San Clemente uh-huh I lived in San
Clemente for a little while and then
lived in Newport Beach for a while and
it turned out that maybe I kind of
wanted to just hang out on the beach and
party a lot more than I wanted to become
a pro beach volleyball player yeah got a
little bit sidetracked so I had to get a
job went to work for a while and I was a
grandma doing around
uh you but around that time yeah she
like hey man you know wake up or she
just let you you know do your thing you
know I wasn't living at home so I don't
think she should know had a full grasp
of what was going on she was always
supportive she was always there for me
when I needed her and you know if I
think that if I just kept drinking you
know I I don't think I would have got as
in much trouble as I did but it was
actually when I started using you know
drugs for me it started with pot
mushrooms and then some guys at work
introduced me to speed which I thought
was cocaine at the time you know
everybody was kind of doing it no I mean
I wouldn't say that but they were doing
it and they were the older guys and uh
they thought it was cool so I tried it
and thought it was cool it was you know
math yeah snorting at or smoking it
snorting it yeah yeah you know which is
just as bad right mm-hmm and the crazy
thing about that drug is you think
you're doing great for a while and
you're on top of the world and you know
six seven months down the road
everything's falling apart yeah and I
had that happen in my life two or three
times where I felt like the most
powerful and productive person on the
planet and then next thing I know I
don't have a place to live I don't have
a job and I'm moving back home
uh-huh and that's where where mom you
know kind of stepped in and today you
know what's going on you know I got to
find some direction for your life and
during that time I decided to enlist in
the military mm-hmm
figured I needed a job I needed some
training I thought it was maybe be a
chance to see the world
they offered me a linguist you know job
or I could learn a foreign language and
that sounded like a pretty good deal
went to basic training in San Antonio
made it through that went to Monterey
and was doing great in my classes and
then started drinking again right so you
were off the meth during that period of
time I was imagine yes yeah still still
drinking though or she cut everything
out for a period of time you know during
basic training there was there wasn't
any drink
or smoking or anything like that but
once we got on base there in Monterey it
was almost like a college dorm setting
right and everybody was away from home
everybody was kind of looking to click
up socially and drinking is is very
prevalent in the military yeah so you
pick it back up and then what happens
next for me it was I would call them
small things you know things like having
too many beers in my barracks that was a
an infraction drunken disorderly was
some Marines that was an infraction
breaking curfew to spend the night in my
girlfriend's barracks it was in the Army
at the time that was an infection and
all these little things kind of added up
to an early discharge but along the way
are those sort of like points in you
know the the the social camaraderie with
the dudes that you're hanging out with
like right on do you know or I don't
think you get in trouble but it wasn't
like oh man you you you tore it up last
night maybe but I mean that that's
that's all false I mean that's that's
not resource I like people could hey you
you know you party harder than anybody
else did last night and then what do you
have to show for it right you know it's
an embarrassing story discharged from
the military uh-huh hangovers I mean
what's the best part about sobriety
never waking up with that to him
headache again one of the many great
things all right so you get discharged
what year was that that was ninety 1995
uh-huh
moved back home for a while started
working again you know try you know I
have lots of stories of starting over
and trying to pick myself up from the
bootstraps
I went to work in some restaurants for a
while but then once I started getting
back on my feet and starting to do
alright then the drinking started again
and I wasn't in the military anymore so
I didn't have to worry about drug test
so you know I started using again found
myself in Hollywood with these big
visions of becoming a rock star
mm-hmm you know I love to play guitar
and I think you know all of these big
visions of grandeur were like I didn't
really know what direction I wanted to
take in my life so I set these big huge
goals so it really didn't matter if I I
made it or failed and you know it's like
at least I at least I tried to be a rock
star but I think that at the same time
they were also aligning myself with what
I really wanted to do was to drink and
to use right and avoid responsibility
right because if you're a rock star then
you can do whatever you want and
everyone cosines it right I mean I did
the whole sex drugs and rock and roll I
mean it just seemed like the lifestyle
and I was already leading that lifestyle
except you know I wasn't a musician yet
right
did you have a band I mean were you guys
plan out or rehearsing at all we had one
band there was four of us and we had
four white guys in a reggae band and we
called ourselves the knotty dreads
uh-huh
no one hits no wonders yeah a lot of
dope smokin and living like in Hollywood
like around sunset or we're exactly
living right off Hollywood Boulevard
yeah right around the corner from the
man Chinese right in the middle of it
yeah so that was what 95 96 that was
around 99 99 98 99 moved to Hollywood
uh-huh and where are you hanging out
like what are the bars are going to you
know a lot of the ones on the strip you
know the the whiskey the Roxy one of our
favorite places was called insomnia and
that's where you could go take ecstasy
it didn't open up till midnight and
didn't close till 9:00 a.m. in the
morning and with speakers that were
seven feet tall and there was a lot of
crazy nights yeah living the dream
oh yeah right so weird is uh you know
where does it start to turn super dark
for you yeah I mean that lifestyle is it
wasn't sustainable for me you know I was
working at a restaurant ended up getting
fired from that job wasn't really quite
sure what to do and a friend asked me if
I wanted to start selling some weed and
I'm thinking you know by now so we'd
sell
make a couple hundred bucks you know
maybe that maybe this is is my way to
keep living this lifestyle and it was
actually pretty lucrative for the first
few months and I was actually starting
to get more customers I was kind of
starting to make more money and I really
thought like maybe this was like the
career path for me maybe I wasn't going
to be a volleyball player or a musician
or a rock star but for some reason the
drug dealer seemed very appealing right
at the time and I remember as I was as
moving up the food chain in the drug
world my dealer asked me to store a six
pound suitcase full of marijuana for him
and I thought great now I have unlimited
supply I can start recruiting my friends
to start selling for me and I thought
that this was was a viable plan and that
was until the two friends that I that I
told had told about it decided they were
gonna steal it from me
Jeff stole the suitcase from my
apartment from me and took off with it
and Morgan his roommate stuck around and
tried to tell me that he was convincing
me that that he wasn't in on it and that
he would help me find Jeff and get the
weed back mm-hmm so how does this unfold
like you come back to your apartment you
look for it can't find it are you it is
that guy there or do you call him up
like how does it go step-by-step you
know it was the craziest story I mean
these guys would come over and hang out
and have a couple beers and smoked a
couple joints and it was a weekday
morning it was about 10 a.m. and all of
a sudden I get a knock on my door and
it's these two guys and usually they
have a you know they have a day job they
have a moving van job or something like
that and it just seemed odd to me that
they were there but they had a 12-pack
of beer and that was the lifestyle that
I was living at the time so I said screw
it and invited him in and during that
time Morgan and I had stepped out to
have a cigarette on the roof and while
we're on the roof of my building looking
over the side I see Jeff running through
the park with the suitcase from my
closet
and from that moment I mean it was like
every scene from a bad movie that I've
ever seen me interrogating Morgan me
calling everyone that Jeff knew to try
to find him and get this weed back you
know it's extremely stressful situation
means you immediately assume that Morgan
was in on it
or did you think he was innocent and
Jeff had just pulled a one-er and took
off with it spontaneously or that they
did they plan this whole thing and that
was the whole reason they were coming
over right from the beginning I thought
Morgan was it on it uh-huh
but I was also giving him the benefit of
the doubt you know I didn't absolutely
no and he was my only link to Jeff so I
thought keep him as close as possible
you know during this time and see see
what happens I also had to tell Marc my
drug dealer that I had lost the six
pounds of weed that he had trusted me
with mmm and what are the stakes there
you know what the crazy part is it
probably wasn't more than 10 grand
mm-hmm
you know ten thousand dollars it I look
back now and think how stupid but in the
middle of it I mean I think there was
more than money
involved there was reputation there was
ego there was feeling betrayed by people
that I trusted trust you know there
there was a lot going on inside that
situation right all right so you know
what happens next really changes the
trajectory of your life forever so walk
me through it yeah Morgan had been
staying with me over those four or five
days while we look for Jeff at the end
of four days
my girlfriend Angela who had been living
with was on vacation with her family she
was scheduled to come back so I told
Morgan that he was going to have to take
off you know that that's when things
changed that's when he said he really
didn't have anywhere else to go
he told me that he was actually in on it
with Jeff but he didn't realize how much
trouble I would be in or you know kind
of like the situation that was going to
cause me and that he was in on it and
that he was sorry and I was I was
stunned you know it was like what I
already knew to be true was actually
being
confirmed and I just sat with it like I
didn't know what to do I had no idea you
know what to do I talked to mark my drug
dealer about it and he basically made it
seem like it was my my problem to solve
yeah and in that moment I did what I
always did I drank I used I got high
later on that night a friend of mine
came over to sell me some more weed so I
could sell that and he suggested that we
started interrogating Morgan to figure
out what he really knew you know if he
was just copping to this what else did
he know
and in that Tara Gatien process it went
from asking questions to getting angrier
to verbally abusing Morgan to the point
where I was actually physically abusing
almost hating him i was i was berating
him i mean all of this like anger and
rage and violence and frustration was
pouring out of me and more than I even
knew was there and during that night I
went in my kitchen and I grabbed a knife
from my butcher block and I I stabbed
Morgan in the chest was there a
particular inciting incident that he's
like he said something or the
altercation kind of tipped into a new
gear that prompted you to escalate it to
that level or you just like high and out
of your mind
you know I I don't other than the fact
that he had actually admitted to to
being in on it I mean it was like when I
knew for sure that this person that that
I was still trying to trust still trying
to use you know to find Jeff had
basically told me that you know I
screwed you from the beginning and that
was that was the turning point for me
and when the floodgates opened with with
with the questions and you know the
first punch
was the was the same punch that led to
the the knife and was there an intention
to like what you know were you like I'm
gonna kill this guy
or are just gonna scare him or I'm gonna
just injure him
or was it just a blur it was definitely
a blur you know I want to take you know
total responsibility for everything but
if you'd asked me you know that morning
was I gonna wake up and kill somebody
that there would have been no way yeah
and I think initially I was trying to
scare him you know more came out of me
then then he that I knew was there right
so you just go after him and how many
times he used to have him one time in
the chest one time that was it and did
you know that was a fatal blow right
away pretty quickly
yeah so would you do the next steps were
really a blur you know because if you
think that go all the steps that were
leading up to it got me to that point
what do you do now that there's a dead
body in your apartment my friend and I
tried to wrap him in a blanket tried to
put the body by the dumpster that was in
front of my apartment building it was I
thought it was the middle of the night
turned out it to be it was like 6:00
a.m. in the morning the Sun was coming
up there was people on the street that
saw the whole thing I mean it was it was
horrible yeah you know there's a lot of
shame around around the harm and the
impact that that I caused to Morgan and
and to his family
in my community to write like Hollywood
I mean I'm sure it's known for some
pretty crazy [ __ ] but for me to be
responsible for that piece of it that's
something I still carry with me so when
you recount the story you know you're
you've told the story many many times
what are the emotions that come up now I
mean still some shame obviously you know
it's it's one of those this is one of
those things that you know no matter how
many amends you make you can never take
it back like there would be nothing that
I would wish more than to be able to
give Morgan his life
mmm to give his daughter her dad back to
give his aunt or her nephew back and
that's something I'm never gonna be able
to do I mean it's there there is guilt
there is shame there there's it's been
something that I've had to work through
and you've if you attempted to make
direct amends like communicate with his
family directly yeah so there's actually
rules against that laws against that
you're not supposed to make direct
contact with the family while I was
inside San Quentin I was able to write
letters of apology and letters of
remorse to his family and then file him
with the Office of victim services in
California and they stay on record there
so if the family ever wants to receive
them they can you know and and part of
that was not seeking forgiveness it was
just being genuinely sorry for for the
pain and the harm that I caused you know
I sometimes I feel like when people say
oh you know wouldn't it be nice to be
forgiven it's like you're asking for
something else from the family members
right like I've already taken so much
away now can you forgive me too you know
you know and I really wanted it to be
more of something that I could offer
them and so in that letter I said I'll
give you ever have any questions or if
there's any further explanation that it
that I can give you know I would always
make myself available to them but they
haven't reached out to you know and are
you notified if they actually pick those
letters up I'm not sure if I would be
notified I I doubt it just the way
things work in California you know with
the life sentence I had to go to a
parole board before being granted
suitable for release at the first one I
was denied three years and I wasn't
found suitable until the second one but
at both of those hearings the District
Attorney contacts the family right and
invites them to they can attend the
hearing and they can also make
statements as to you know how it
impacted them
and whether or not I should be released
that neither of my hearings did Morgan's
family show up right and what became of
Jeff I found this out later on and I
think it's it's mostly true he testified
in court you know during my legal
proceedings that he got on a Greyhound
bus to Las Vegas with the suitcase full
of weed they got almost all the way
there and then got pulled over police
stepped on you know that guess they
asked everybody to get off the Greyhound
bus the police went on with dogs grab
the suitcase confiscated it and no
charges were pressed no charges no
charges why would that be I don't know
if they could tie it to him you know
being where it was at on the bus or they
were just I'm sure that there's a
suitcase that size for the weed has a
certain odor to it so yeah and it wasn't
legal back then like it is now so it
wasn't and what it was a random search
or was there a bolo out on this guy
because you had been arrested I'm not
sure now yeah I'm not sure I mean all
they would have to do is dust it for
prints right guys prints would be all
over the thing like I don't even know
that I mean that you're nodding yeah
this story is you know if I didn't go
through it I wouldn't have believed it
myself
Wow so how long is it before you're
apprehended I was arrested the same day
yeah yeah I mean there was too many
people on the street they were the
police were called within an hour there
was there was helicopters over my
apartment building
mm-hmm you know I was arrested and
detained immediately you know drunk high
handcuffed in the back of a police car
and what was the interrogation process
like I mean did you keep your mouth shut
did you cop to it
I kept my mouth shut you know it was
wasn't until 15 months you know going
through the arraignment process and
talking to an attorney trying to figure
out what the the best next move would be
it wasn't that I didn't know I was
guilty it's just I didn't feel like I
knew how to had all the answers in that
situation you know I was talking to my
family I was talking to an attorney and
in the end I decided that the best move
for me was to plead guilty mm-hmm
and to accept a plea bargain for 16
years to life which was incredibly tough
because at the time Gray Davis was the
governor in California and he said if
you take somebody's life you're never
getting out of prison and back then it
didn't matter if he had 15 to live 25 to
life a hundred to life you weren't going
home right but you know that that was
also a moment way and not when I knew I
had to you know take ownership of this
thing and regardless of the
circumstances I was going to try to
become somebody different so you had
that awareness from the beginning you
know from the moment that I took
Morgan's life that was my my turning
point that was the moment where I
realized there was no more
rationalization there was no more
normalizing where drugs and alcohol had
gotten me to in my life you know I was I
was able to justify just about anything
but not that you know and what is the
you know emotional experience of
digesting the possibility that you may
never get out of prison you know I think
there's a lot of sadness and there's a
lot of fear I didn't want to go to
prison you know but if I could have
found a way out of it I would have taken
it you know and that's who I was back
then
you know selfish self-centered didn't
want to take accountability didn't want
to you know believe that I was that
person and if there was any way out of
it
you know I would have taken it but the
moment that
I actually did say like I'm gonna accept
this I'm gonna plead guilty you know it
actually freed me in a lot of ways to
move forward because you were just
aligning yourself with the truth like
there's no more hiding from this reality
yeah exactly I mean that's that's that's
what it was for me you know I didn't
even know how to be real and honest
about what it actually happened and you
didn't talk to a whole lot of people
about it during during that time yeah
but just just the act of kind of
resigning myself to whatever fate lay
ahead you know I realized that there was
a chance that I would never get out of
prison however I think one of my
superpowers is optimism and I gave
myself you know hope along with it with
with the hope that that I got through
spirituality and God that there would be
a chance for me if I did everything in
my power at least I would have a chance
and I kind of use that to propel me
forward so ultimately you end up in San
Quentin but that's not where you were
initially no yeah
San Quentin you know has a notorious
reputation but it's a level 2 prison now
level 2 being kind of the
middle-of-the-road prisons and level 4
being the most violent and lockdowns and
a lot of racism and a lot of craziness
going on and when you're a young guy and
you have a lot of years to do that's
where you start and for being you know a
white kid from the suburbs going to
prison for the first time on a level 4
yard was a pretty scary experience and
so explain it to me like my only frame
of reference is you know what I see in
movies in TV so what is the reality of
being dropped down into that environment
where it's about you know racial
identity and gangs and alliances and
survival yeah I mean I think I've seen
all the prison movies right before going
in but I don't think I understood how
racially segregated
prisons are so when I went in I was
expected only to hang out with the white
guys
there was actually politics saying you
know you don't eat with anybody from
another race you don't play games with
anybody from another race I mean it was
almost ganging up you know by race
instead of neighborhoods but and that
wasn't the way I was was raised or grew
up but in that situation you kind of
conform to to what everybody else was
doing inside there right and and what is
the kind of general threat level like
are you just on guard constantly or you
just learn how to align yourself with
the right people to be protected like
what is the day-to-day experience of
just trying to wrap your head around
like what to do and what not to do just
to get through it yeah I mean I think
you learn from from the guys that you
hang around with I tried to learn as
quickly as possible right to figure it
out talk to as many people as possible
and figure out what's going on here for
me it was difficult not really knowing
who to trust and I had turned to God
very early on when I was in the county
jail even and so I continued on that
path while I was in prison which is not
very popular in prison you know I think
the majority of guys say that anybody
going to church while they're in prison
is hiding behind the Bible meaning that
they're you know they were this badass
coming to prison now why are they going
to change all of a sudden that's
interesting I wouldn't know I wouldn't
have thought that so so you are so you
you make that decision under like some
level of threat then you know I still
remember the the first day on the yard
that at high desert state prison and all
that all the white guys come and hang
out at their table they shake hands they
greet each other and is it like a white
supremacist thing to like if you watch
the movies it's like if you're with the
white guys then they're skinheads and
they have like swastika tattoos and
stuff like that those guys were there
but actually
they were kind of like a more supremest
group out of the white guy right there
was another fringe white dude group yeah
they definitely took it to the to the
next level but you know so just because
you're hanging out with the white guys
doesn't mean that you're a white
supremacist or that you were a skinhead
right
so everybody's greeting each other and
they do the call for church they say
whoever wants to go to church go and
line up by this gate and we'll let you
in and so I knew that that was the path
that I was on I knew that that got it
had gotten to me this far I was doing a
lot of my own study and research inside
the Bible was trying to understand some
of these stories trying to figure out
who Jesus Christ was you know I grew up
a Christian but never really knew who
who the God of the Bible was so it was
really important to me to stay on that
path and I remember breaking away from
the group and walking across the yard to
go to the door that lets you into the
church and when I looked behind me I was
the only one I was the only guy you know
making it making this walk across the
yard and it was an incredibly like scary
feeling like I was separating myself
from from the fellows so to speak and
you know I as scary as that was I think
that was the decision that made all the
difference in the man that I was going
to become what was it that made you feel
like this was the path for you though
like you you you said you're very clear
that like you know God had delivered you
to this moment
was there an instance in which something
happened that made that clear to you
you know other than the fact that the
way that that God came to me while I was
in the county jail I mean it was that
there was a small group and there was
like a Sunday school teacher who almost
taught the Bible to us like we were we
were little children and I remember
telling us the story about Zacchaeus you
know that this this small man that
wanted to see God and wanted to see her
Jesus was coming through the town and he
wanted to see it but they that the town
was too crowded and he was kind of a
smaller person so what he did was he
climbed up in a tree to see God and I
just remember that story like touching
me in a way like I needed to be
explained about God in the Bible as if I
was a child you know I wasn't in a place
of spiritual maturity and that's the
first time I mean that was the turning
moment for me mm-hmm and did that
coincide with you getting sober I mean I
think they happened at the same time but
I don't think one led to the other yeah
for me honestly like like waking up and
realizing that I was a person that took
somebody else's life right was the thing
that said I will never use ya again yeah
and did you see were you going to like a
meetings in in prison in jail yeah at
San Quentin you know they had AAA
meetings we had a Saturday night home
group they they gave out chips that they
made in the furniture factory they they
let guys share you know about their
sobriety some are real some are [ __ ]
but how many people show up at the a
meetings in San Quentin there was
actually quite a few
you know they had they had five or six
nights of AAA during the week yeah
and as lifers and as guys that have to
go to the parole board and especially if
your crime had something to do with
drugs or alcohol you need to show the
parole board written documentation of
your attending right so lots of guys
they're just getting getting the sign
offs exactly right did outside groups
bring meetings into you because I you
know I've done that kind of thing at LA
County Jail yeah where you go in and do
meetings with the guys yeah there was
several several outside groups I mean
almost all of them I don't think any of
them were in mail it right they had you
know and that was the nice thing about
San Quentin to is they did allow and
encourage a lot of community support to
actually come inside the prison and
offer these programs mm-hmm so it seems
like it was almost a relief then to get
to San Quentin
which seems
ironic and not what you would expect
yeah it took seven years you know I was
incarcerated seven years and I think to
go from level 4 to level 2 in seven
years was was a blessing in itself I
think that was well below the average
you know a lot of guys don't make it for
10 to 10 to 15 years just because
there's a lot of trouble that you can
get in along the way and any kind of
right up
makes your points stay Jack died so you
got to keep a low profile and just I
mean the idea is to just be as invisible
as possible I think that's a pretty good
strategy as much as possible and and you
are in a chaotic prison environment
where anything could go down at any time
right right so you were able to get
through that part though without any
scrapes yeah you know and I think a lot
of that was was I God had a plan for me
and I think he kept me out of certain
situations and he also provided a lot of
opportunity for me along the way and if
I knew that was going to happen on day
one you know the fact is I didn't I
didn't it took 15 16 years inside prison
and looking back and going you know wow
a lot of things added up and align
themselves along the way when you
reflect back on it now setting aside the
you know the fact that a life was
sacrificed in the context of this can
you find some gratitude for the
experience because of the principles by
which you live your life today yeah I
mean definitely it's very easy for me to
say that saying Quentin saved my life
mm-hmm and if somebody were to ask you
how it saved your life how do you answer
that it you know I think when little
kids get in trouble right that parents
put them in timeout
this was my timeout you had an extended
timeout
I mean it was huge but it caused me to
wake up you know it gave me a lot of
time to self-reflect
which I don't think people outside of
prison have or you know they're they're
busy with their jobs in their lives and
and here I was you know I was sat down
for a while you know it wasn't the best
of environment or most conducive
environment but it also caused me to
take my life very seriously and I never
wanted to let that time be wasted you
know I applied myself to every group and
program an educational opportunity that
was available you know I was able to go
back to school and earn that college
degree that I want your degree I was
never able to do you know in the in the
free world you know there was a veterans
group inside San Quentin where I was
probably a much better
airman than I ever was you know while I
was at the Defense Language Institute
there was a run Club there's a
thousand-mile Club yeah where they would
meet you know every week and at the
beginning of the year we would run a
benchmark mile to see how fast you could
run a mile and then over the course of
the year we were trained and increased
the distance and every year in November
they actually run a marathon the San
Quentin marathon which is you know we
don't we don't have a very scene of
course it's it's a hundred and five laps
around the same quarter mile loop of a
prison yard and I think just that the
training and the camaraderie and the
discipline that goes into that I mean
your urine endurance athlete so I'm sure
you can relate yeah you know that that
was my training ground for things so
much more than just the physical I mean
the mental and the emotional and the
spiritual you know that's where
everything tied in for me you had this
facility though this ability to grab
onto all of the lifelines that were
available to you you know when the
confines of this situation most people
don't right I would imagine what do you
think it is or was within you that gave
you that like engine or that desire to
to reinvent yourself with the prospect
that you may never get out whereas so
many people just can't get to that place
yeah I I mean I understand what you're
saying and I agree with you for me it
was it was faith and it was optimism and
and not given up I just
that piece was has never been in me like
I said I think optimism has biz
had been my greatest and my worst
quality at the same time because you
know here is this person with with an
unlimited potential you know he could do
anything he wants but he wants to screw
it off for for becoming a drug dealer
but at the same time when I was at my
lowest you know and then things were at
the darkest it's like I refused to to
give up on myself
and not just for me yeah I was going to
say how much of that was fueled by this
sense of attempting to atone quite a bit
yeah you know you know you know and like
atone DeMorgan attorn atoned to his
family atoned to my family right the
people that have loved and believed in
me you know my whole life and wanted
better things for me you know it's
really hard for me to even understand
that the shame in the embarrassment that
I caused them and yet my mom and my
sister were there you know every month
and spent a lot of holidays inside
prison inside saying Quentin sharon
vending machine food but but sharon
family time together supporting me
through an incredibly difficult journey
and you know hard on me and hard on them
too yeah i mean you could have just gone
down a spiral and become further
entrenched in the behavior patterns that
led you to that place but you have this
ability to really take advantage of the
limited resources available to you I
mean you didn't just graduate from you
can just get your degree when you are
the valedictorian right walk me through
the speech that you gave that left
everybody in tears
that was pretty incredible because when
I got the same Quentin you know I had
gone to a gret I went to the graduation
that was going on there and a friend of
mine was actually given the
valedictorian speech and you know I'm
like how did you do that and he's like
well I had that I had the highest grade
point average and I quote well [ __ ] I
think I can do that and I want to make
that speech because I've served seven
years in prison at institutions where
there wasn't a whole lot going on for
guys there was in school there wasn't a
a there wasn't self-help and I was
pretty pissed off you know I was angry
there wasn't a lot to do except work out
and read books and uh you know watch
your time pass by and I said okay I can
I can get this valedictorian and I can
make this speech and I can go up there
and I can Rage Against the Machine and
tell them everything that I thought was
was wrong and it took me two and a half
years of going to every class of showing
up early as day in late of doing all the
homework I remember there was one time I
even got a B+ on a paper and I wrote an
additional paper explaining why I
thought it was an a paper and they
actually changed the great but what I'm
saying is I was dedicated now yeah I did
not really believed in in this speech
that it that I wanted to write that's
interesting so this the speech was
really the driving thing behind all of
it I think so I felt like I had a lot to
say and for those four seven years I
didn't have much of a voice right that's
like the ability to have a little bit of
power in a powerless situation yeah and
I got to that day where it came down to
me and and one other guy and I actually
beat him out with with the GPA and so
they told me and I went down to write
the speech and as the word started you
know coming out my pin it was different
right somewhere along the way
somewhere along the way by my message
changed right I went from anger and
despair and feeling like I didn't have a
voice to one of gratitude because there
was so many people and I was able to
wake up and see and look around and see
like you know these people that came in
and teach these college classes they
didn't have to do that right they chose
to do that they they saw something in us
not that the guys in Saint Quentin and
the guys in the college program and the
guys in the last mile and I mean the run
Club they saw something in us that that
I didn't see in myself
and so I wasn't angry anymore it was
like I felt accomplished you know and
like in those courses like the more I
learned about the world the more I
understood that I had a place in it I
had a responsibility to it you know and
they didn't serve where I was going to
be angry about it or to complain about
it you know I really wanted to take
ownership of my voice and my place and I
felt like I had a lot to offer at the
graduation ceremony I was allowed to
have my mom and my sister attend and
hear this speech and it's a pretty
amazing to allow them to actually come
inside the chapel and out see this
graduation ceremony and I remember when
I was going through trial my sister or
my body was biological mom had gone back
to school and the week that her
graduation was scheduled for was the
same week as my trial and without
hesitation she skipped her graduation to
come support me during my trial and so
this was my this was my moment to try to
say thank you to her
and thank you to my mom and thank you to
just all the people that had been there
for me and supported me on this journey
the warden was there and I remember
asking her to stand up and just telling
them that story in recounting how it
happened and the entire place gave her a
standing ovation
I was crying she was crying what she was
crying more than me I guarantee you but
I wouldn't be surprised if the warden
was crying that day yeah it's
interesting I mean that's a huge
breakthrough right to be plotting and
planning this speech where you're gonna
you know say everything that's been on
your mind about how you were wronged or
what needs to be changed and then to be
delivered to that place and take a
totally different tack you know is
spiritual growth so then the last mile
comes in after that right or is it or do
I have that wrong no that's right
actually uh you know the same friend of
mine that had made the valedictorian
speech he just happened to be the same
guy that invited me to the the first
last mile a demo day my friend Kenyatta
and he said hey you should come check
this out and I hadn't heard about the
last mile before it was a new program I
think there was five guys involved and
so I went to their demo day and these
five men shared their business ideas you
know half the guys filled from four
inmates you know inside prison and the
other half were venture capitalists and
media and tech people from the
surrounding community and they were
talking about these mobile apps that
they were developing and the business
you know ideas that and the value
proposition and who it was going to
impact and who was gonna help and and
they did it in such a slick professional
way I mean I felt like I was watching
shark tank and it was just amazing I
mean I was so impressed they were
talking about tech that we had no access
to for 17 years I didn't have access to
a smartphone or email or the Internet
and I knew that this was a program that
I wanted to be a part of so essentially
the last mile was started by these
entrepreneurs who wanted to bring coding
education to inmates as a way of giving
them some skills some training so that
when they get out they have something
marketable to share and part of that is
this demo day where the inmates who have
been studying coding create these
businesses and then they have the
opportunity to pitch them to that
Side world these feces these investors
and other startup companies I guess
right exactly that that's accurate
yeah fairly accurate I mean it started
out as an entrepreneurship program they
didn't know if it was going to work
there you know is it was a brand new
idea and then Chris red lights in
Beverly per any the the people that
founded the program came up with the
idea to introduce computer coding which
at the time I would have said what was a
crazy idea you know it just it just
never happened before
you know inmates didn't have access to
computers yeah how are you supposed to
learn how to code when they they you're
not connected to the internet right
that's a good question
but you know they set it up and they
talked to the people they talked to
administration inside the prison they
talked to officials in Sacramento and
they got the green light you know they
partnered with the PIAA industry
Authority there at San Quentin uh-huh
and they created a computer lab you know
18 computers they had applications and
interviews I was accepted as one of the
first 18 guys to go in there you know
it's a pilot project they didn't know if
it was going to work they didn't know if
we were gonna be able to learn it then
you know you're gonna teach them
computer coding now you know you're not
they're not gonna go back there and kill
each other you know learning something
so challenging but they gave it a shot
and we gave it a shot and we didn't have
access to the Internet but what I mean
what the hell well we barely even knew
what the internet was yeah except for
what we saw on TV or in magazines
something like that so did you grow up
with any kind of inclination around tech
or was this a brand-new bizarro new
world you know I was a videogame nut
when I was a kid you know long before I
was addicted to drinking or using us
addicted to video games I used to play
them all the time you know I never
thought that maybe I could turn that
into you know actually coding or writing
the software that makes these games so I
think I had that much experience I
remember messing around on American
online you know before getting locked up
that was about the hottest thing going
they had cell phones back then but they
weren't
very smart so there was no Facebook that
was yeah and it's weird like all this
technical innovation is happening so
quickly without you being able to access
or be informed about it it must have
been wild when you got released like it
was a whole new world all of a sudden
out there yes so crazy good yeah but
yeah so you know that they started
teaching us HTML and CSS and JavaScript
how to write build basic pages and and
and write some applications and some
functions that are data structures
algorithms you know we didn't have
access to the internet so we didn't have
the same resources that that guys and
gals on the outside would have but there
was a lot of like grit and determination
and and also there's exposure to
computers that I think really inspired a
lot of guys to try to learn this stuff I
know I did I fell in love with it
because I felt like it combined the math
and the language perfectly for me you
know I would go back to my cell at night
with a computer coding book and get my
little notebook and a number-two pencil
and practice writing uh toy problems you
know how to how to figure stuff out with
code and it wasn't until I was back in
the class the next day that I could
actually see if it worked right but when
it did I mean it just I feel like it
really strengthened my own
problem-solving abilities which applies
to code but also applies to life and how
many guys were part of this program so
there was 18 initially selected to take
part in the program it was just supposed
to be a six month you know web
development course at the end of six
months eleven guys passed with a high
enough proficiency to where they started
a track to you know so continued
learning and so there was a track 1 and
track 2 for additional learning you know
we started learning node and WordPress
and react some some backing and coding
languages too like Python and Ruby so it
was pretty cool I mean the stuff that we
were able to learn one of our projects
for the track too was actually to
build the apps that we had been pitching
in the Entrepreneurship program so
Fitness monkey was selected as one of
the programs so we developed a personal
health and recovery tracker which is the
model for for the app that I'm
developing today but what it does is it
tracks people's clean time and it also
allows them to log workout data and then
combine these two metrics to give them
charts and visualizations about how to
stay clean and sober and so how long did
you work on Fitness monkey before your
demo day where you got to get up and
pitch it two months oh that's it two
months and it was a group project so we
enlisted other other people on the team
and we kind of split it apart we didn't
have a lot of time and then of course
you have to take a little time to
rehearse right presenting this hitch in
a professional way right yeah and so who
shows up for a demo day well quite a few
people there was people from Facebook
there really there was people from
Airbnb MC Hammer was there yeah he's
sort of one of the mentors right yeah
he's on the board of directors and also
just a big supporter of the last mile
and also tech it's been amazing to have
him you know and I was there for I was
in the coding program for two and a half
years before leaving San Quentin so I
went through track one and track two I
went on to attract three program that
was kind of setting up the joint venture
program so in the track three we were
able to build a a social media dashboard
for Airbnb mmm that went to Twitter and
Facebook and pulled back there their
likes and their follower accounts and
recent posts that was incredibly
difficult because we didn't have access
to the Internet and we learned how to
use those api's and get that data we had
to build our own fake Facebook and fake
Twitter to practice passing the data
back and forth to see if it worked
yeah just so you could like test it out
without being connected on lines crazy
yeah well I do know that when you did
pitch it on this demo day that it went
well because there was an article in
TechCrunch
yeah whoever was there said like when
you got up and did your thing the guy
was like this his pitch was like is
better than a lot of the Y Combinator
companies that I've you know heard give
their pitches like you had it dialed
right yeah that's amazing that's a big
compliment yeah I mean that's TechCrunch
I mean that's no small thing and what's
interesting is that this program is the
anomaly because when you canvass what's
going on in our prison industrial
complex certainly not enough
rehabilitation programs going on right
and this is a maverick situation you're
a shining example of you know what this
rehabilitative process can produce but
we need so much more of this right like
when you kind of reflect on your
experience how do you think about prison
reform what you know what worked for you
and what can be changed to produce more
examples like yourself yeah that's a
that's a great question and and I think
you know you're exactly right or I
honestly believe that more needs to be
made available to people while they're
inside because yes you know the crimes
have been committed and people needed
you know I believe that prisons you know
for people that commit crimes need to
serve time right out like I believe that
I believe that there should be
consequences to our actions but then how
you treat those I mean I believe that's
the punishment right it's not like I'll
go to prison and then treat them
horribly while they're inside I mean if
it really is about rehabilitation then
you need to give these men and women
skills and tools and self-help that's
going to help them become better people
become assets to their community and I
think that more can be done you know
from from from both sides you know like
from the private sector people allowed
to come in like the last mile but also I
think the state has a certain
responsibility to be involved engaged in
that rehabilitation you know for a long
time I was lock him up and throw away
the key so it didn't really
matter now more than ever people are
being released from prison you know who
who have served their time who ever
rehabilitated themselves who have gone
to the parole board and been found
suitable for release you know and a lot
of that was done under Jerry Brown and
then also I believe Gavin Newsom is
gonna have a big part in that as well
yeah you know I'm certainly no expert in
this field but I do know that you know
statistically the number of inmates
incarcerated where the offense has some
relationship to drugs and alcohol is
super high it's probably in the 80% you
know range or something like that and
recidivism is super high you know I you
probably know the statistics of how many
people end up back in prison or
reoffending certainly it you know it
needs to be punitive but it needs to be
a balance of punitive and rehabilitative
and I think the pendulum is too far on
the side of punitive and not enough in
terms of rehabilitative and you know
from a pure economic perspective it's
not a good way to operate the system we
don't want people going back in and to
the extent that we as it's like what
kind of society do you want to live in
you know I would like to live in a
society where we're punishing people for
breaking the law but we're also
providing them with the tools necessary
to rehabilitate them such that they can
be productive members of society
whenever possible right and this program
should be considered like a pilot
program for other types of programs that
you know can bring these services into
the inmates and provide them with a
sense of purpose as well yeah no I
totally agree it's been amazing to watch
that the last mile go from from an
entrepreneurship class to a coding
program to you know having success
stories inside San Quentin
but it's also growing it's expanding the
last mile is in eight prisons in
California now including women's prisons
there
expanding outside of California to
Indiana to Kansas Oklahoma in January
mm-hmm
and one of the most amazing things that
happened actually after I was released
was they started a last mile coding
program in a juvenile facility down in
Ventura and they allowed the graduates
of the program at San Quentin to get on
a Skype call and mentor the juvenile
guys going through the the program and I
thought just what what an amazing
experience you know because I think that
the younger people that are in that
situation are so much more apt to learn
from people that have gone through an
experience that and have that kind of
like street cred so it's amazing to it
to watch the last mile grow and how it's
evolved when I did actually get released
on may the fourth 2017 I went to work
for an internship with the last mile
they asked me and two other members of
the last mile to go down to Y Combinator
and pitch a learning management system
so I was able to take all the skills
that I learned you know pitch in Fitness
monkey to go and try and pitch and
basically what we were doing was trying
to take the coding program that's at San
Quentin and putting it into a piece of
software that's now being distributed to
all these other locations oh wow that's
cool yeah that's amazing so we didn't
happen to get picked up by Wong Y
Combinator at that time but then I also
learned that they didn't pick up any
nonprofits so I felt like we did all
right that's cool
do you now go have you gone back to San
Quentin in some kind of mentorship
capacity to check in with the program
there yes
the last mile actually you know it
started out as the one classroom and it
was inside an old print factory
warehouse so there was a lot of empty
space the last mile has now turned that
empty space into five different
classrooms they're going to offer a
design program they're going to offer
CAD CAM they're expanding into AI t
there's a new partnership with Google
the guys in the program and the joy
venture program have developed their own
offline search engine called jolt which
basically almost like your attacks being
online yeah I like being on Google but
now it taps into all like the videos and
the PDF files and the resources that are
available there it was just getting too
unwieldy you know everything was every
place on the on the server and so they
created their own search engine which is
amazing you know there's a lot of talent
back there and a lot of you know just a
lot of guys that I really believe are
doing the work to earn their freedom and
earn their their humanity right and
that's the part that I really want to
shine a light on that I don't think a
lot of people see so explain that a
little bit more fully you know I think
you know a part of that me saying like I
didn't feel like I had a voice for a
long time I feel like people in prison
are portrayed a certain way in media and
on TV and in film and if that's all have
people ever watched you know what would
they think about somebody like oh yeah I
got an ex felon living next door to me
you know I really wanted to see like the
positive things that are going on the
college programs the veterans group the
run clubs you know the last mile you
know guys learning to code I saw you
know the prison yard change after the
last mile arrived meaning you know there
used to be guys out on the yard doing
push-ups and pull-ups and playing
handball or whatever two guys walking
across the yard with a computer coding
book in their hand going to the the gym
to sit down and you know practice
studying together I mean it's amazing
yeah that's a that's a long way from
press and license plates all right yeah
that's wild so where does fitness come
in I mean it's like an everyday thing
for me you know not is it always that
way though I think very early on it's
encouraged right because it's not the
only thing to do right you know
especially on the level for yards if a
riot kicks off I think you're gonna be a
one in good shape as opposed to bad
shape so it was almost mandatory that
the white guys to be out there working
out you know and that was out of
survival not you know out of was out of
this love for working out
then it was also a great way to pass the
time and for me I had a lot of a lot of
extra energy that I thought I wasn't
putting into drinking or using anymore
mm-hmm
it became my sanctuary it became a
meditation you know either running like
I said start doing yoga right did yoga
so there's like proper wood they were
like yoga classes every Tuesday night
really yeah in the Buddhist chapel there
was about thirty guys really and an
instructor named James Fox that would
come in from the outside it was part of
the inside prison project and yeah I
mean you know you're you're in a crazy
environment but but what a better place
to like just explore the the body and
the breath and the stretching and the
breathing I mean for me it would really
made a lot of difference in just how to
cope with a lot of difficulty yeah and
then running yeah I mean running that
was something I fell in love with and I
wasn't a runner you know my whole life I
don't think I ran my first five miles
until I got to San Quentin you know I
was in the Air Force but that was only
maybe a couple miles at a time yeah but
I remember running that first you know
20 laps or whatever it was and the
feeling that I had you know afterwards
and also there's this like in prison
you're never alone and when I was
running on the track that that was my
time just to be with myself and be with
my body be with my breath be with the
things that were you know running
through my mind so did it start with you
just saying I'm gonna run around the
yard or was there a group saying come on
we go we run at this time
join us at that you know actually at the
time I was trying to learn how to play
tennis believe it or not San Quentin
actually had a tennis court and a tennis
team I'm painting a very different
picture and I had in my mind
yoga classes and tennis sorry to spoil
it for everyone yeah
but uh it was pretty amazing and I
really wanted to learn how to play this
game tennis you know I didn't grow up
playing and I remember that I wanted to
be fast enough to get to every tennis
ball that was hit my way so that's why I
started running and I just found a love
for running that went beyond you know
just being quick or fast
yeah I remember on my birthday my 38th
birthday I decided I was gonna run 38
laps around this track it was nine and a
half miles a few months later there was
a half marathon and then that November
you know I ran a 105 laps 26.2 miles
around the the San Quentin prison yard
all in the same direction orgy switch
direction no it's all the same
directions under four hours is that
pretty good not bad
101 of the hazards is if there's an
alarm
everybody has to sit down so so right in
the middle of your marathon if there's
an alarm you got to sit down and I think
it to pause your time yeah they did they
do pause the time but not your legs or
your you know everything that stretched
out or sore and you know you can't train
like an endurance athlete while you're
in prison you don't have access to the
same health care you don't have access
to the same foods you know that was kind
of tough inside
I personally was diabetic found out when
I was 31 years old Wow
type 1 or type 2 type 1 want yeah and it
didn't hit me until late in life so I
had to learn to manage that you know
insulin and food intake and storing some
extra jelly packs from the peanut butter
and jelly on the side just in case my
blood sugar dip low while I was running
and what is your relationship with
running visa the recovery like explained
to me like the healing powers of running
in weathering that experience being
inside and stinks over yeah for me for
me it gives me freedom it gives me
release it gives me a connection you
know like I said it's my meditation you
know in a lot of ways I gives me time to
think I have friends who I run with on
the outside and that allows me
camaraderie and friendship you know I
recently had a friend of mine named
Eddie he did 14 years and he was
released and he had actually won the San
Quentin marathon so he was pretty fast
as well but it's all in a flat track
so I took him to my hometown 10k in
Lafayette thinking you know he might be
a little bit faster than me but I think
I can get him on the hills I'll be
damned if you didn't get night overall
in that's pretty good yeah
I would suspect when you're inside it
also provides you with a sense of agency
you know like it's something that you
can control right or you can try to try
to master you know in the same way that
you know the last mile is providing you
this you know ability to develop a skill
like there's something about running
like that you can own that's yours
yeah I mean I think that's true too you
know and especially I mean it's not
always about the race or the event right
it's about all the training that goes
into getting there and who I was able to
become during that process right there's
a lot of discipline involved there's a
lot of preparation learning to wake up
and show up and what is the relationship
with between fitness and sobriety for
you but for me I think it's it's it's so
strong it's like that really helps me
manage my life like even when things are
at the roughest I can go for a run and
feel better you know I think that is a
wonderful program I go to and I believe
in a lot of their spiritual principles
but I don't believe that that's the the
one-size-fits-all for sobriety I think
there's a lot of different ways and I
think for me fitness and running are
really what helps keep me sober mm-hmm
that's interesting
yeah I mean a got me sober it keeps me
sober I'm you know very active member of
that community and fitness for me is a
huge tool that I use to maintain my
sobriety I think the danger for me and
I'm interested in your response to this
is when I start to think that like
fitness is my higher power or that
Fitness is the solution
- you know my addiction problem that's a
danger zone for me right like it's a
tool and it helps me but it's not the
full game for me yeah and I would agree
I don't I don't think it's the full
thing yeah I think there's a lot of
different pieces to it and it comes in a
lot of different forms you know whether
it's higher power or whether it's a a or
whether it's the big book whether it's
running marathons you know I I was very
interested to find out how many people
actually you know recovering addicts do
you know train for endurance as crazy
numbers yeah especially not in the ultra
community so many people are in recovery
lots of tattoos lots of piercings and a
lot of recovery time if somebody should
do a sociological study on what exactly
that's about because I think it's
fascinating yeah so I think there's
definitely is a switch you know in the
brain somewhere that you know you're
trading one for the other you know yeah
say oh I'm becoming addicted to working
out you know but did it ever cause the
negative side effects that you know
right I mean I think that it's too
simplistic to say that but it's also not
something that should be dismissed like
a lot of people in recovery are
dismissive of that no I didn't do I'm
not trading one addiction for another
but I think if you're being really
honest with yourself you all there is an
aspect of that friend of mine says that
the drink or the drug was always the
easy choice and like runnings hard so
they don't exactly correspond directly
in that way but I want to believe and I
like to believe that on some level
addicts and alcoholics are seekers
they're spiritual seekers they're
looking for answers to what ails them
they're just doing it in a very
unhealthy way and on some level in
sobriety and recovery that search can
continue through endurance sports
because it is a template for self
exploration in a healthier way
it can be misused just like drugs and
alcohol not perhaps that you know and as
dark
away but you can have an unhealthy
relationship with running or sports or
fitness of course but I think that they
are you know tools for for that
spiritual expansion if used correctly
and so it doesn't surprise me that so
many people in recovery find their way
you know towards these ultra events or
marathons or what-have-you you agree I
think I'm on board okay I feel like
we're saying the same yeah yeah yeah
right and you've gone on you've run
marathons and I know that you like when
there's like a structured running event
in San Quentin
you get buddies together on the outside
and do the same thing yeah solidarity
runs as a matter of fact this Friday I
imagine if the weather permits you know
the air quality with the fires and stuff
but um they're gonna have the San
Quentin marathon right so uh if you're
free I'd like to invite you to a
solidarity right oh wow cool what day is
that happening we could do a fire we
could do a Friday Friday some Friday is
well I'm gonna be back home but I could
do it from where I live maybe that
sounds good yeah all right you're gonna
hold me to that do you still run
marathons it's been a while it's been
it's been a minute you know I'm always
relatively marathon ready but I might
have to stretch maybe if we all took
like a half or a quarter or something
yeah all right break it up we'll follow
up on that so walk me through the parole
hearing that culminates in your release
how does that come about it's your
second second parole hearing yeah the
second proletarian was in December of
2016 it had been 18 months since my
prior earring which I was not found
suitable you know basically for lack of
insights and you know you really don't
understand how you got to that place
where you committed that crime and
looking back do you think that was a
fair assessment at that time it's hard
to say you know I don't want to be too
critical because I'm not in that in the
role that they were in I felt like I had
done everything in my power to be found
suitable that day mm-hmm and I think
there's a lot of other factors that go
into whether guys do or don't
get found suitable I rationalize it now
saying it just wasn't my time yet and
really what it allowed me to do was have
another 18 months to to work on myself
yeah to learn more in the computer
coding program to gain more insight into
my causative factors and so I felt
really prepared the second time you know
what I went in and there's no guarantees
I mean I knew it and what I did do
differently was just start to open up
more I felt like maybe at that first
hearing I was a little bit closed off
you know they'd ask a question and I'd
give him a quick answer and so I didn't
want to make that second mistake the
second time around I remember that first
hearing was about two hours and my
second hearing was four and a half hours
of talking about everything you know
from childhood to drinking and using to
becoming a drug dealer to how I'd use my
time in prison and really trying to give
him a clearer picture of who I was today
it was him pretty incredible that you
know there's two commissioners sitting
on the panel and my attorney had
submitted an article from the Christian
Science Monitor to one of the
commissioners so while one commissioners
asking me questions the other
commissioners reading about me in the
last mile program and so when it came
time for him to start asking me
questions he was very complimentary
which I didn't trust inside that hearing
because you don't know how it's gonna go
but then he also said you know there's a
lot of people that come in here and say
that they've changed and he goes I can
see by everything that you've done today
that you have and that was a pretty
amazing feeling and then you go through
the hearing and they ask you to step out
and they deliberate and they call you
back in and then they read the
disposition so they decide write that in
there yep smile so you know right then
and you know when they told me that I
was suitable for release there's a lot
of release of emotion you know you know
I felt like you know they were I never
knew if I was going to home and now that
now that they said yes you know I knew
that I was gonna have a second chance at
life it was an amazing day and you don't
get out that day yeah it's not yeah yeah
there's that what is the time period so
there's a five-month review process the
parole board gets to review the hearing
for four months and the governor
actually gets the last 30 days so
there's a possibility that it could be
revoked yes yes and I've seen it happen
several times but usually around cases
that involve women or children or
multiple offenses mm-hmm
so have a man so you get out five months
later whatever how do you begin the
process of trying to piece your life
back together I mean it sounds like the
last mile I mean these guys you know God
bless them but what a massive support
system to have behind you as you try to
integrate back into the world yeah I
mean going into the parole board you had
to have a pretty good solid parole plan
together so I had a transitional house
through the California re-entry mmm
Institute program they run an 18-month
life skills program inside San Quentin
before you're released and then once I
got released I was able to transition
there the parole board required that I
live in transitional housing for six
months which I think was a good thing
you know after being away for so long it
was nice to have a soft landing so to
speak the last mile offered me that
position with them to work with them
over the summer to continue furthering
my skills and and figure out job
prospects from there I was able to
reconnect with family you know mom and
sis and you know I felt like just as
much as I had been locked up for 17
years they had to so I feel like you
know on the day that I got out they were
released from prison too and I went
about trying to rebuild a life and I'm
still there right I've been out of year
and a half and
still learning on a daily basis and
still grinding to try to learn more and
you know a lot of that's for me and a
lot of that's for my family and a lot of
that's for just trying to continue to be
a good person and make amends for my
past what do you think people
misunderstand or don't really appreciate
about the process of trying to
reintegrate after an experience like
that that's a good question I think
there's a lot of things you know maybe
maybe they don't understand I think
people try to be supportive but just to
really don't understand like well what
it was like to be away for that long I
think there's a lot of things like you
know technology you know for one I was
only inside 17 years but I see guys kid
now and now that have been locked up
3540 years so to put a smartphone in
their hands and say figure out Gmail or
Star Trek right yeah so when you went in
it was basically like a little bit of
AOL and then you come out and it's like
iPhone 7
basically yeah there's Facebook there's
Instagram Google Maps kind of blows my
mind you know it's no exposure to that
whatsoever when you were in did you get
some limited like supervised internet
time no no I mean I kind of knew what
the things were because from watching TV
and reading magazines you know Wired
magazine was one of my favorites so I
was kind of learning about the stuff
without actually being able to touch it
yeah that's weird to get wired and to
read all about everything and not have
the ability to experience it yeah and I
think I actually think that gal the
video game training that I did when I
was a kid helped you know figure out
smartphones and figure out you know apps
and and you know Spotify blows my mind
the fact that you have unlimited music
you don't have to go to record stores
anymore which is yeah I kind of miss you
not have to you kit you really can't
because they die anymore right yeah yeah
I mean I you know I I can't even wrap my
head around what that would be like and
how do you think about like the ongoing
process of like making them
and for taking a life and what do people
not understand about that I think I
think one of the misconceptions is that
I need forgiveness to move forward like
well like what happens if you know one I
don't know if Morgan's family even knows
who or where I'm at today you know I'm
not really quite sure about the
relationship but what if I never receive
forgiveness you know from his family and
I think the misconception is there is
that you know it's forgiveness that
forgiveness isn't about me I can
continue to move forward and be a
positive person and try to make amends
for the life that I took by becoming a
changed human being vibes by somebody
that you know although those character
defects that I talked about selfishness
and self-centered is doing the opposite
right being someone who cares being
someone who's empathetic being somebody
that helps other people being of service
and sharing my story with other people
is really important to me and I think
that's another thing like a lot of times
when guys getting out of prison they
don't really want to talk about it right
they're trying to become new people so
let's not really talk about the past or
let's skirt over the past and I didn't
want to do that because I didn't want
there to be secrets in my life you know
if there's something that I want people
to know I want them to hear it from me
and not somebody else in observing you
share your story and just kind of being
around you at nansuk a project like my
sense is you feel strongly and compelled
to share your experience and it's not
that you're reluctant but there's a
little bit of like awkwardness around it
like you strike me as somebody who's you
know your quiet dude you know you're
probably like a private guy like you're
not like some extrovert who wants to get
up and like spin a yarn like you're
you're doing this because there's a
sense of obligation and perhaps you've
been called to do it but it doesn't it's
not like this supernatural fit for you I
think that is that fair
that's totally fair and the hardest part
is not telling like the the
rehabilitation story you know because
it's talking about myself and you know
all the things that I was able to do
while inside prison is pretty easy but
going back and talking about what led me
there I think that's the hardest part
and that's the thing that I struggle
with too is like how much of that story
should I tell I can be really open and
honest and graphic about it you know but
what purpose does that serve you know I
may have my it might you know some
morbid curiosity for people that want to
hear like well what we wouldn't down and
how did that happen but I don't think
that's the story I think it's really
about somebody that felt lost and
insecure and felt betrayed and lied to
and did something that was horrible you
know and I'm talking about me I don't
feel like I was ever supposed to be on
that path but yet I found myself there
and if it could happen to me I think it
could happen to any one of us really I
think we all have that power to decide
inside of us like what path we're going
to take you know and sometimes we make
good choices and sometimes we make bad
choices they don't always lead to the
taking of a human life but I think it's
in there right it I don't think people
are inherently evil like that I think
they get distracted by things that
happen in their lives maybe their
childhoods maybe what's going on in
their community that you know and it's
important for us to be aware right like
never never put ourselves on like a
higher plane than then where we're at
it's important to be aware that that you
know good and evil lives within us all
and we all have the power to decide yeah
it's very easy and convenient to point
your finger at somebody and say I can't
believe that person made that decision I
would never do that
and rather than snap to that kind of
judgment try to have a little bit of
empathy and understand what led to that
choice right like you you haven't walked
a mile on that person's shoes or had
their life experience you know I think
we're all like you said it's
like it's not a binary thing of good and
evil like we're a mash-up of all of
these things and we're a product of our
environments and you know if you have
had the life experience of that person
who made that bad choice chances are you
you know very well may have made that
same choice and now to be on the other
side of it
with what you have learned and this path
that you're continuing to blaze I mean
it's only been a year and a half since
you've been out you know what is the
message that you're trying to convey
about the rehabilitated version of
yourself and what's possible yeah you
know I think I think it's important for
me to let people know that change is
possible the rehabilitation is possible
even for a murderer and then I also want
to give the guys that are following my
footsteps a lot of hope too right
because when we started you know the
last mile or when you know when we were
going through that program we didn't
know that there was going to be jobs
waiting for us and now that we're having
success stories you know we have guys
working at the Chan Zuckerberg
Foundation there's an apprenticeship
program at slack fandom has now two
last-mile graduates mm-hmm working for
them you know I've been with them for a
little over a year and another friend of
mine Jason Jones just started his
internship so I would encourage him to
keep working his butt off and I think
it's great that that tech communities
are starting to embrace this idea of a
second chance yeah I had to be
precarious to put all of this energy
into developing this skill without any
assurances whatsoever that you would
ever be able to apply it in the context
of a job that would you know heyyou
a living wage I mean you can there's
fitness monkey you can have your
entrepreneurial journey but is anybody
really going to give you a second chance
was a question you know very much open
at the time right definitely and
honestly my entire car serration that
was one of my biggest fears mm-hmm right
I know how hard I can work
I know everything that I can accomplish
was inside will that ever you know
provide an opportunity when I get home
yeah so phantom gives you this chance
that I mean it was an intense interview
process though it wasn't it oh my gosh
it was an equal four and a half hours
long as that as the parole board not
quite as tough but still pretty tough
you know these guys are had been in that
the coding industry for a while know a
lot about what they were talking about
and they were kind of putting me through
my paces to see what I knew I was able
to talk about projects that I worked on
with the last mile I showed them Fitness
monkey though the prototype app that we
built I showed him the Airbnb dashboard
and at the end of the day they offered
me a 90-day internship AHA and in terms
of that interview process though how
much of that was based on assessing your
technical acumen versus like is this guy
gonna be safe like are we gonna be able
to cohabitate with this dude like in a
work environment I didn't even think
about that really cuz it's like alright
we're gonna hire this guy he's been
convicted of murder you know he got out
but like okay he can code like he's got
that part handled but like are we really
gonna hire this guy and take this risk
like if something were to happen yeah
you know no that's a huge piece hit the
finger would like really you hired this
guy like and look what happened
you know the liability yeah so the
exposure is so gigantic that it really
is this leap of faith no I see what
you're saying you know and and you know
I think there's a lot of truth to that
you know maybe it was more than just the
code I was focused on that part of it
right I figured that was my job but I
would imagine you probably convinced
them of that and short shrift you know
it's more of like a character thing like
if we have them around here for four and
a half hours eventually we'll be able to
see who the real Chris is yeah and so
I've met with like four four members of
the team you know the product manager
the detect the tech lead the engineering
manager and got the internship but two
weeks into the into
Jib they asked me to present at the All
Hands meeting you know and there's over
500 employees at fan domain eight
offices around the world and they asked
me to tell my story
mm-hmm and that was really tough to
write like who these people I'd been
working with for two weeks who didn't
know any of my background story but at
the same time I wanted to share it with
him because I felt like fandom did take
a chance on me and believed you know not
only in my abilities but my ability to
integrate with the culture was that the
first time that you kind of shared your
story on a group level it was you know I
think you know that the people that I
was in the interview with knew knew my
story but you know the entire office
didn't and I was able to go up there and
and tell him just in a real and open and
honest way just like I shared the crime
with you today you know I'm kind of what
led up to it but then also the the
rehabilitation journey and I was
pleasantly surprised that after sharing
my story with them I went from the 45
year old intern to somebody with a lot
of life experience and a lot of a lot of
information and experience to just to
share with them were there people after
that who were like I just thought you
were like I couldn't figure out why you
were so old must have like blown a few
minds I mean it had to be word must have
passed around before that though like
hey this guy got out of prison that's
sitting next to you and the cubicle no
I'm not sure I'm not you don't know
exactly how much and uh none of them
called me the older intern to my face
right not to your face
I'm sure yeah
is it weird that you're somebody who's
kind of gotten a lot of attention I mean
you were getting pressed when you were
still in prison like there's you know
just researching getting ready for this
today like there's articles being
written because of the last mile program
and you being a shining star within that
you were getting attention while you
were still incarcerated and that's just
continued as you've gotten out
is that like a weird thing like it's
sort of like why me for some reason this
is God's plan perhaps you know the
spotlight is being shone upon you and I
feel like you're somebody who recognizes
that and has made this decision to carry
that responsibility forward to you know
share a message of of hope and
rehabilitation yeah no thank you first
of all and uh yeah it's weird you know I
never imagined myself doing this many
interviews or podcasts or you know being
on news programs yeah it's not exactly
the most glamorous thing to have you
know the light shined on me for for
being in prison and doing all these
amazing things but at the same time
that's where I'm at mm-hmm you know and
I do feel an obligation to kind of pay
forward you know all that that's been
given to me I think you know whatever it
was in my brain is I was one of the
people that wasn't afraid to be
interviewed and tell my story just like
I wasn't afraid to go for that
valedictorian speech and and tell them
everything that was wrong but you know
at the same time you know I believe in
the message you know and that's one
thing that the last mile has taught us
is to believe in the process and at
first I didn't even know what that meant
because I didn't know what process they
were talking about you know and it was
believing in the program it was
believing in yourself and you know
believing that you had the ability to
figure things out even when the answers
aren't so clear so when you say believe
that you believe in the message that
you're putting out there succinctly like
what is that message that change is
possible yeah I mean I think that
everybody has pain moments and bottoms
in their life and perhaps they're not as
severe as what you've had to weather but
the power in your message whether you're
a felon who's listening to this or
somebody who just feels stuck in their
life with some obstacle they're trying
to overcome
there is hope and inspiration in the
ability or the wherewithal within all of
us to tackle and overcome those
obstacles that we face and if you could
come from a life sentence and staring
down the barrel of having to live with
the fact that you took another person's
life and still find a way to move
forward and put your life back together
to atone to be in this process of making
living amends I think that there is
inspiration for all people who are
struggling in their own ways with
whatever they're contending with in
their lives and so there is value in
continuing to tell the story and I would
imagine that this version of the story
that you tell will continue to evolve
because if there's one thing that I've
discovered it's like in telling a story
like the story you start to learn more
and more about what it is what's
important about the story and what
people are connecting with you know and
I think that will be an evolutionary
process for you as well but it was
interesting to hear you tell it to share
it at Nantucket how did you Tom told the
story of how you guys first met like he
was touring San Quentin what was that
experience like there was something
about you that he connected with and he
felt compelled to like stay in touch
with you yeah I mean I I still remember
the day that that he came inside even
though I didn't really know who he was
you know at the time and we were talking
about you know life in prison and the co
diem program I showed him the fitness
monkey project and somehow we got on the
topic of sobriety you know and I talked
about being clean for 16 plus years you
know and he talked about you know
recovery in his own life and kind of
what helped him and he says that there
was one question that he asked me that
really stood out is like when I go back
home at night and you know am I happy at
the first thing I had to correct him on
was I don't go back home I go back to a
cell Oh
which we both chuckle that but at the
time I said yeah you know I'm not
exactly where I want to be I'm not
you know fulfilling everything that I
think I could live up to but you know in
this moment I'm doing everything I can
and that was enough for me you know and
he said that he went down to another
conference a few days later with all
these millionaires and billionaires down
there and he said he looked at all of
them and didn't see one of them that was
as happy or content as I was inside San
Quentin so I mean I think that that's
what impressed him
since then I've gotten to learn about
the Nantucket project and I think it's
an amazing organization the way that
they share conversations and stories
about things that are going on in the
world and with people it actually
reminds me you know on a bigger scale
but a lot of the different groups that I
did while I was inside San Quentin you
know or I'd sit in a circle of 10 guys
and just get real and open and honest
about what's going on in our lives and
what's going on in our pasts how we got
to here and you know who we hope to be
so you know when Tom asked me to share
my story for the Nantucket project that
was an easy yes yeah how did that feel
being up there doing that crazy nervous
yeah yeah you know especially the first
time I think the first time not this
year but last year you know I got
interviewed by Kelly Corrigan and she
was asking me all the tough questions
kind of like you were asking me today
and sharing that conversation and I'd
only been out of prison for a few months
like what if I do get this event but all
he's like posh people and I'm sitting
here and at idyllic Nantucket and
there's boats going by and lighthouses
and it was beautiful and I can't explain
you know fully explain with with any
kind of like reason or understanding how
I ended up and then tuck it except for I
just kept saying yes to all the positive
things that were going to my life you
know and in saying yes to opportunities
that presented themselves you know I
truly believe that life is defined by
the things that we say yes and no to yes
to education you know yes they're
improving
you know your condition yes - trying to
make the most out of bad situations you
know so when they asked me to go give a
talk at the Nantucket project and you
know I wanted to say yes that - right
and this year they they screened this
East of Eden film that Tom and his team
put together desert is that gonna be
available viewable by the public do you
know from what I told it's still a work
in progress huh so I'm not quite sure
yeah to be honest yeah it was definitely
impactful so following up extending that
question that Tom asked you that day
about going home what does it feel like
now when you lay your head on the pillow
what are the thoughts that run through
your mind life is pretty good right now
I mean there has to be a tremendous
amount of gratitude for having this
second chance but I imagine it's more
complicated than that because it's mixed
with the confusing emotions around you
know what led you to that point yeah I
mean I I feel like I have a good
understanding of what led me to that
point you know and I've taken
accountability and taken ownership of
all of it
you know there's parts of it that I'll
never understand you know how much pain
or how much harm that I caused but
further for the pieces that I can from
my side of the street I feel like I've
done my part and that's really what
allows me to move forward and continue
to try to grow and progress and and
build a life you know because I feel
like in a lot of ways I am grateful for
all the opportunities that's been
provided you know a place to live
working you know opportunities to share
my story getting a girlfriend you know
they're like real real real life stuff
getting my own apartment you know all
these things are things that I haven't
done in a long time and I'm having to
figure it out you got a girlfriend now
sort of all right
[Laughter]
so yeah I'm not gonna publish this for a
while so I you never know but yeah how
does that go like dating and having to
you know be upfront and honest about
your past oh my gosh have you heard of
these dating app things I've heard of
them I've been married a long time oh my
gosh they're nightmare they're such a
blessing and a curse because they're
supposed to allow you to interact with
all these different single people and I
remember I was in I just gotten in the
transitional house and I downloaded one
of these apps while like I send her it
wasn't tinder but it's close and I
remember you know I didn't have a car
yet I didn't have my own place I think I
still had a curfew you know right so I
wasn't the most eligible that's the view
but uh there was a girl in the town
where I was living and I said hey look
I'm new in town why don't you show me
around and she's like new in town
where'd you come from oh my gosh she at
the moment of truth right it's just
right up front
immediately and it comes quicker than I
realized it every time but I said San
Quentin and she goes you were in prison
I'm like yeah and there's a story if you
if you'd like to hear it and this girl
was nice enough and brave enough to hear
my story and we kind of texted and
chatted for a few weeks and went on a
bike riding day down to the park a few
weeks later and dated for good six
months uh-huh
but I found like like I said I don't
want there to be like part of my story
that I have to hide with people I want
to show up on a daily basis and be
genuine and authentic and you know that
means telling some of the dirty truth to
sure yeah it's gotta be a challenge to
navigate that I want to wind this down
and I'm trying to think of the best way
to do that I I think you know on this
theme of second chances if somebody's
listening to this and they are stuck
maybe they just got out of prison or
maybe they just want to you know lose a
couple pounds or run their first
marathon or you know they're in a job
that feels like a dead end or is
unfulfilled
what is the you know message that you
want to leave with that person about the
prospect or possibility of making
fundamental changes that can alter the
trajectory of your life and and and you
know give these people their version of
your second chance that's a great
question you know how do you how do you
how do you boil it down to two anything
is possible to don't it's like when when
when you have nowhere to turn like you
hit your bottom and you make these
changes they're forged out of pain and
they're forged out of you know being
placed in a cage where your options are
very limited right and you're compelled
to confront yourself in a very real way
without very many other options and in a
certain respect other people may be on a
very slow drip version of that like
they're not it's not so bad that they
have to change right but they're unhappy
they know they want to change and it's
almost like hitting that bottom is a
blessing because you are compelled to
change in a certain way you know most
people don't reach that it's like like a
heavy drinker is not an alcoholic you
know what I mean like that person may
drink for the rest of their life and
never get to that place of seeing
sobriety like in the way that you or I
do yeah I mean I think my bottom is as
horrible as it was
and I needed it you know to make a
change you know I look back and wish it
didn't take that much pain to make a
turnaround I wish there was a shorter
cut for other people who you know maybe
they want to change or maybe they think
they should change to actually you know
find the grit and determination to do so
I think decisions are made you know
based largely around that whole pain and
pleasure you know if one thing feels
better than the other that's most likely
the thing that you're going to do you
know so if there's any I don't know if
there's anything like be taken from that
maybe it's you know spend more time in
the in that unhappy place right just to
just to get clear I'm like this is
really what I don't want and then you
can go around and start taking the steps
to get to where you do want because it
is possible you know I'm living an
example that that a life sentence can't
hold somebody down and at the same time
I don't think everybody's taking that
path yeah it's good talking to you man
very nice doctor knee rich how do you
feel you feel all right I feel okay good
talking for a long time we haven't
talked for a long time I feel like I
want to go running my stuff all right I
did - cool thank you man
my heart goes out to you have a lot of
empathy or sympathy I should say not
empathy because I can't imagine what it
is to walk a mile in your shoes and so
much respect for all the hard work that
you put into change in your life and my
hope and my wish for you is that you
continue to be a beacon of light for
those that suffer and continue to share
your story of hope and transformation
and rehabilitation because it's powerful
and there's a lot of people out there
that are suffering and I think you can
be of service in a very fundamental
profound way
to a lot of people so thank you for
sharing your story with me today thank
you cool and if people want to connect
with you they want to learn more about
fitness monkey and what you're up to
how do they do that what's the best
place for people to go sure Chris at
phandom dot-com mm-hmm email you
directly yeah you want to do that you
can get a lot of emails I heard I heard
you had a pretty big following oh cool
and are you uh are you on any of the
social medias yes you are I am on
facebook and instagram at nuke
Schumacher nukes Schumacher and we
should say because it took me a beat to
learn this there's an extra H in your
last name that's easy to overlook
yeah sho spell it yeah SC h u h ma CH ER
yeah it's that you H in the middle there
that might trip you up so make sure you
do that correctly
cool man all right thank you cool
talking to you these how are you feeling
right now how did that one land for you
it's pretty intense
I get it but I really appreciate you
listening all the way to the end I'm
sure Chris does as well and I think that
was an important conversation to have
and I hope you agree do me a favor let
Chris know what you thought about our
exchange you can find him at nuke
Schumacher on Instagram and Twitter and
uke Schumacher with three H's SC h u h
ma CH ER and christian marker on
facebook if you'd like to support our
work here on the podcast there's a
couple simple ways to do just that just
tell your friends about the show or your
favorite episode take a screen grab of
it share it on your favorite social
media platform tag me subscribe to the
show on Apple podcasts on Spotify on
YouTube wherever you enjoy this content
leave a review on any of those platforms
that's helpful and you can support the
show on patreon at rich roll com forward
slash donate I want to thank everybody
who helped put on the program today
Jason camiolo for audio engineering
production show know it's helping me
with the scripts on the intros the
interstitial music and
so additional music today by my pal movi
blake curtis and margo Lubin for
videoing the show in general not today
but in general Jessica Miranda for
graphics DK David Khan for advertiser
relationships and theme music as always
by analemma appreciate the love you guys
I'll see you back here in a couple days
with a great conversation with Brian
Koppelman very much looking forward to
sharing this one with you brian is a
former music business executive and
record producer turned writer filmmaker
you may know him from rounders or as the
co-creator of the show billions on
Showtime and we had a great exchange
it's good one so until then be kind be
compassionate be empathetic be cool
peace
[Music]